歡迎回來趙華
艾倫說
我們今天的大來賓
是一個非常久違的
我大概是使出了千萬斤之力
沒錯
才把他請來
因為今天我們的第一集
需要一個重量級的
好 我先來歡迎他
就是富邦投顧的
董事長陳怡光 光哥
趙華 艾倫 各位觀眾大家好
歡迎光哥
謝謝 歡迎
好久不見
終於又把你請回來了
因為你到富邦經控一段時間了
一年
是 一年
一年多 一年多
一年終於有時間來了
是 是
很高興能夠再看到造謊
我第一次啦 我是第一次看到光哥
我在台灣節目看你們
追蹤你們的節目
非常非常棒的一個節目
太好了
所以我們才有榮幸請到光哥來
而且這一年來
台股從一萬七千點的低點
已經漲到四萬點了
沒錯
真的是一年喔
對等關稅的陰霾
似乎都已經完全沒有了
是 沒錯
所以今天趁著光哥來
因為現在國內各投顧
應該都有一個困擾
排股漲太快了
是 對
其實我們在去年年底的時候做展望
其實我算了一下
平均差不多高點36,000點
差一點
我們在34,000點
現在全部跑掉了
是
應該年中中間的中
所有的投顧應該會重新改變
今年的這個高點預測
其實現在目前預測高點
沒什麼太大的意義
因為已經沒有
上檔已經沒有所謂的壓力
只剩下支撐
所以我覺得投資人在
進入4萬點
這樣的一個快速列車的過程裡面
其實應該選股不選股
會變成一個投資的主旋律
好 不要困在指數到底幾點上面
沒錯 我們有多
我們這邊也是讓我們的觀眾
再回味一下我們的帥氣光哥
光哥現在是富邦投過的董事長
當然有非常多的頭銜
明星產業的研究員
其實最早光哥有研究過面板
我們以前要一起跑
看光電業
沒有啦 您是長官
光電業今年其實看起來
也有一些有轉型
所以它的整個產業
是有在做轉變
光哥是最年輕的投股動作
我當時在衣經投股
應該是45歲
就先當上關股的動作
那時候滿幸運的
光哥現在不是也才45歲嗎
謝謝
那要認料嗎
不過其實以前光哥
不一定是想要走金融業
其實早期光哥有透露過
他可是在我們東森隔壁的
補習班的老師
沒錯
其實我一直覺得這個補教業跟證券業
投僱業其實很像
其實一直是從個人的IP轉到投僱的IP
這個比較不一樣
那影響可能是影響學生的分數
變成是影響投資人的資產
我覺得這比較不一樣
但是在整個這種所謂的工作內容上來看
其實都是把一些複雜的東西
化繁為簡
然後介紹給學生
介紹給我們的投資人
你有提到一件事情
就是台股現在叫做
越漲越便宜
其實就台股的整體來看
其實我們從這次的
2月28號
應該是兩義戰爭開打
到現在應該兩個月
那剛好它的戰爭權力法
也剛好到時間
所以目前看起來
比較不確定因素
最糟糕的時間點
可能在三月份
因為三月份我們看一下
台股差不多跌了4,050點
然後開始之後
就開始一路往上走
那目前看起來還是在高漲震盪
那我覺得目前主要觀察點
還是在於這個
川普他這邊的一個支持率
因為你看那個TACO指數
TACO指數的高點就是
這個股市的低點
那這個是我們給他的TACO指數
我剛剛提到有
1 2 3 4 4個方向裡面都有看到
然後這個部分我覺得
可以跟這個我們的好朋友
稍微提一下就是
你可以用10Y來看油價
跟用10Y來看這個指數的高低點
假設這個10Y在4.5以上的話
其實這波就要小心
現在4.43
其實你就要開始要有點
要有點警覺性
因為4.5以上的話
代表就是說油價可能在120以上
這個部分我覺得從
這個每天交易的
10年關於直律率去看
是不會騙人的
這第一個
那第二個就是說
你去看這個4.5到4.2這個區間
那油價就是100到120
那就是像現在這個位置
就是在這個地方區間
那假設接下來的這個史歪
跌到4%以下
那這個油價應該就是
跌到90塊錢以下
那代表這個戰爭應該已經
已經慢慢的已經
進入所謂的最後的階段
這個我覺得從這三個情境
我覺得會比較容易去判斷說
到底現在的一個位置是
油價是多少
然後股市的這個表現是多少
那這個可能可以拿來
當作是一個參考
不過我們錄影的此時
有一個現象比較奇特
就是油價其實也往上跑
因為美疫戰爭看來
有些新的變化跟進度
但是股市卻似乎不太受到影響
對 它若是在120
沒有衝破120
我去看過過去的這個
過去幾次的11次的
過去6次的衝突裡面
其實它到120以下的話
其實指數是上漲
然後比較嚴重的應該是在
發生的當個月份
就是2月28號的3月
下個月3月份
其實影響是最大
然後後面開始指數就反彈
那下一波假設
它這一波的油價
衝到120以上的話
這個可能就要小心
它的pullback的壓力會比較大
所以我們覺得就是用這個
時間關係的指示欲來判斷
它到底油價會不會沖上去
但是我這邊倒覺得說
油價會有低延性
因為我們現在跑塑化產業
其實塑化產業的這個產業鏈
其實蠻長的
你若是現在戰爭結束了
其實你要去重建
它的這部分的一個油管
还有它的这种
所谓一清二清三清的
这样的一个实化产业
其实需要一点时间
所以我们认为说
即便由战争
在这个时间点结束
其实它会延连两到三个月
通膨还是会上来
所以我们对下半年的通膨
其实第二季的通膨
我们会比较不乐观
对第二季的通膨不乐观
我们相对来会觉得
比较需要
所以光哥 我觉得有个问题
对 我们现在讲的是
因为行情
大家现在可能预期的未来
是要降息的嘛
当然今年可能
没有这么顺利
但是通膨
假設好像戰爭不打
剛剛光哥有提到
我們油價可能會長時間維持在
90甚至100以上
那這樣對於長線的
所謂的降息的壓力
或者說長線的通膨預期
它不會對經濟造成比較明確的影響
艾倫真的是很厲害
直接問到重點
最年輕的投資就是當後選人
其實我們在看產業是這樣
我就看一條線
那條線叫菲利普曲線
菲利普曲線有兩項線
這個就是橫的部分就是Job Market
然後直的部分就是Inversion
就是我們講的通膨
那那條曲線其實告訴你就是說
現在美國的就業市場是兩好三壞兩好三壞裡面就是包括新增費用就業人士還有事業率還OK那三個比較不好就是職缺率0.81 0.9其實不好現在過去正常應該1.3
所以它職缺率代表它
Open的這個工作不是太理想
那第二個就是薪資成長率
薪資成長率MOM也是來到
兩到三個百分點
是目前近幾年的新低
然後再來就是我們看到的
就是它的這個我們講的
失業率跟新增
還有出領
就是出領失業就業人數
有在走高
所以兩好三壞
所以這一塊我覺得
會是WASH
它面臨的第一個問題
那第二個問題就inflation
剛剛艾倫提到就是說
假設這個油價
它倒車入庫
它這一波有稍微
跌破100塊錢以下以後
油裝滿之後再往上衝一波
那再往上衝一波的話
那這個通膨目前看起來
是在3.3
那核心通膨不到3
但是四月份通膨的預期
應該是會到3.8左右
那五月份看起來
有機會突破到4
那川普最擔心的就是
痛苦指數
什麼叫痛苦指數
就是把失業率加上這個
CPI兩個加起來
如果到10%以上的話
其實它鐵定一定要塌口
所以目前看起來
還是壓在6跟7
因為現在的通膨3.3
然後失業率4.3
差不多7點多
還算可以
但是這個通膨我覺得
假設倒車入庫
這個通膨再把它拉上去的話
我們在之前有提到
就是說通膨有三個部分
就是一般公共產業的通膨
就是看油價
再往第二圈走
就是我們講的co-cpi
就是講核心通膨
再來是超級核心通膨
這三塊其實會有螺旋式的上揚
那上揚的話
我們就是擔心
第二季其實最大最大的灰溪牛是
Stature Flashing
就是我們講的停滯性通膨
那停滯性通膨當然是
它經濟要衰退
可是以目前看起來
它經濟又不會衰退
但是他經濟去年第四季才0.5
今年我們只能預計在1.5到2%左右
目前看起來是低成長
可是假設你的通膨是4%
你的經濟成長率是2%
你的實質的經濟成長率是-2%
因為你是被通膨給吃掉
所以這部分我覺得
可能就是我們必須要留意的就是說
他是否這隻灰犀牛
會在今年的第二季
或是在選舉之前
美國11月3號選舉之前
他有做所謂的這個
停滯性通膨出現
這個是我們比較擔心的
那這個出來的話我覺得
它會變成是緩跌
緩跌的話是我們比較不喜歡的
反而在樂觀的氣氛中
提醒大家有這個可能性
但是你剛剛也有提到
如果是這樣的情況
也不太可能降息了
可能10年期供在折利率
還要往上跑
那川普還有什麼籌碼呢
對 其實你講到重點
就是今年你要想要降息
其實我們內部在討論
其實你今年不要升息就
不錯 就偷笑
因為如果是以現在的點贈圖來看
其實6月18號 19號是最關鍵的時間點
我覺得那個時間點可能會是一個轉折
為什麼 因為WASH是第一場的
這個所謂的
他上任的記者會
而且那一場有點證圖
那你去看3月份那個點證圖
他原先是有
在去年年底12月份那個點證圖
是有8位是認為今年要降兩馬以上
那後來到3月份只剩5位
那我現在很擔心
就是6月份假設出來
以他這次的記者會來看的話
有可能
這五位還有三位會跑票
那只剩兩位認為
今年會降息兩馬以上
那Miller絕對是支持
比較屬於鴿派
那就若是這樣子的話
我覺得那個點陣頭出來
我覺得市場上會很shock
就是說剛剛艾倫所問到
就是說今年可能他降息是遙遙無期
那會不會升息
這個我們就會給他一個 question mark
這個我覺得可能就是一個灰犀牛
因為景氣資金加籌碼
我們現在把資金放在前面的話
利率地毛一定下去
3.5到3.75
是他原先預計要降到
3%以下的中性利率的時候
他還維持在這麼高的利率
其實對於整體的科技業
是比較不好的
那你如果是這樣的話
推升的10年關愛值率
10年關愛值率的倒數
就是本益比的概念
我剛剛提到現在這4.5
4.5倒數就是20倍
本益比20倍
可是你現在科技類股本益比
動不動就25倍 30倍
那就會造成這種比價效應
這個我覺得會是
比較擔心的問題
好不過這一波說實話
美股本來就比我們壓抑
就是戰爭開打的時候
其實美股還一度
極大指數跌到年限
可是台股卻是一個衝衝衝
所以美台股會在第二季
如果有這樣的隱憂的話
會合而為一
還是各走各的路
我想這張表我覺得非常棒
我覺得
我可以解釋
為什麼這一波行情
會走這麼急
我覺得這張表
我覺得
在趕什麼
我真的想了
很久我覺得
我要去解釋說
為什麼可以
衝到140兆的
這樣的一個市值
那這樣的市值是我們
我們過去沒有看過的
那就變成說
我們從獲利角度來看
其實我從這張表的
這個左邊這邊來看
從2016年到2020年這五年
其實你這樣這五年看一下
它平均
平均一年的獲利
2.18兆
這五年很短短的
這時候都沒有AI
所以代表就是說
台灣的基本盤
台灣基本盤就兩
差不多2.2兆
就是我們假如獲利沒有AI的時候
我們知道2.2兆
然後開始在COVID-19完之後
我們開始進入4.32兆
4.02兆 這兩年
應該是Decoupling 鍛鍊
好 就是疫情紅利對不對
疫情紅利 沒錯
那時候你記不記得貨櫃三雄
還有這個所謂的電子股的這個鍛鍊
所以它突破到4.32兆 4.02兆
然後2023年這個部分消化庫存
所以你看獲利沒有上來
到2024年之後
拜登開始他的這個所謂的AI
進來
飛鴻供應鏈開始暖身
然後正式飛鴻供應鏈
完全的
沒有所謂的那個紅色供應鏈
2025年川普
一月上任
跳到4.5兆
然後現在進入了2026年
6.2兆
6.2兆其實這個是
我們自己內部估的
所以你會發現
從這樣的角度上來看
從過去五年
每五年它的一個
循環這樣的轉變
從過去的傳統的
我們講的NBPC
那到後面我們到這個
COVID-19的這樣的一個鍛鍊
這兩個階段完了之後
直接跳到AI
那你去發現 你去看一下
2016年到2020年
台積電的EPS
那時候是12塊 13塊 13塊 14塊 19塊
然後
然後蔡好清楚
對啊 你再來看
2021年是19塊
21塊半
32塊 34塊
是66塊
2025年是66塊
2026年現在
現在我去看所有的
Market Consensus
給他的EPS最高100塊那你去看6.2兆裡面假設他是100塊的EPS代表他一年賺了將近2.8兆2.8兆你減6.2兆
他就佔了四成的獲利數字
再加上AI的整個供應鏈上來
所以這個部分會長這麼急的原因
其實是有機之談
現在的投資人還沒有辦法
去適應這樣的問題
就是因為他對那個獲利數字
他沒有辦法感覺
但是你去看
台積電一季的獲利數是
22到23塊
這樣的一個
第一季已經公佈出來的數字
這樣的一個內容上來看
其實是過去
我們在剛剛講2016年
它一年才賺12塊
它一季賺兩個資本額
所以這個改變
就變成
我要跟好朋友分享就是
AI不是一個產品
AI是一個供應鏈
它這個one star shopping
就是說你打入這樣的一個
這個群組
我們講說這個AI的群組
其實你這個獲利是會上來的
所以如果是照這樣的內容來看
你再去看過去的這個指數
12682我們在2020年7月27號
先touchdown
然後到2024年花了43個月時間
才到2萬點
然後又花了22成元到3萬點
然後不到4個月就直接供4萬
那5萬點了
對 你講到重點會越來越快
它的那個時間會越來越快
因為這個叫做戴維斯雙擊
所謂戴維斯雙擊就是說
當你EPS調升的時候
你股市也往下
你的本益比往下走
本益往下走
你股市往上走
股市往上走
那你的EPS再調升的時候
你的PE是被往下
就變成越漲越便宜
越漲越便宜
投資人就一直追
這個我覺得是
目前看起來
我覺得這張表
可以去解釋就是說
我們若沒有AI
你去看東南亞國家
菲律賓 馬來西亞 印尼
或者越南可能還有一些代工AI
那你去看他的股市
其實他的股市都不是太好
馬來西亞這些都是沒有AI的國家
其實印度
這種沒有很純的AI國家
你看這次有AI國家
亞洲就三個嘛
台灣 日本 韓國
韓國漲六幾% YTT
台灣的那個
那個OTC也漲了超過四成
那其中市場也超過四成
那日本也超過兩成多
所以如果是從這樣的一個
麥克風來看的話
其實有AI你就是變成
你要去
你就會享受到
你這樣子所帶來的
這樣的一個效果
所以我們就把它收斂成
今年來看好了
今年來看你看我們
我們做的這個核心持股
我們自己內部的核心持股
它的QOQ其實是
一路往上走的
它的QOQ當它往上走的時候
因為MOM看短線轉折
QOQ看中線轉折
YY看長線趨勢
那你看它這個是QOQ
QOQ它也是一個
所謂微效曲線上來
所以我覺得這個部分
你不用去預設高點
原因是你就把基本面前搞清楚
然後你再看他的整個獲利數字
他還是會上來的
所以可預期的2027年
剛剛趙華提到
會到5萬點嘛 對不對
那就是說他不是不會到
只是說時間到底什麼時候來
就是看他獲利數字
假設我沒有6.2兆
這樣的一個內容來看的話
你去看5月15號即將公佈的季報
我去算過
台灣差不多平均一季的這個
年代價值是不是10%
你去看低劑的獲利
低劑的營收
假如我沒有記錯是14.33兆
14.33兆你乘以10%就1.43兆
1.43兆是歷史新高
而且我是用最低的8%10%來抓
那如果是我沒有正常1.5兆
1.5兆乘以4的話
因為是足跡往上走
就6兆
目前我去看所有的法人
在今年的預設來看
還沒有估這麼高
我們用這樣的一個
基本面出發角度上來看
為什麼我們剛剛提到說
為什麼會越漲越便宜
是在於它的獲利數字追上來
那搭配我們的資金
其實非常寬鬆
主要是因為ETF
ETF這個滾雪球效應
其實是我們有生以來
看到最成功的一個產品
因為你看
現在股票型的ETF
跟債券型的ETF
呈現黃金交叉
它現在的AUM是6兆
0.5兆的主動式ETF
加上1兆的共同基金
4.5兆的被動式基金
加來6兆
現在的債券才3兆多
本來是1比1
那現在變成說
他把債券的資金
流到股票這邊來
再加上我們有6兆多的
這個超貨儲蓄率再轉進來
那就變成所謂的類法人
這個類法人很可怕
因為我們台灣跟韓國有點像
台灣的散戶大軍比台灣
韓國的散戶大軍比台灣更強
但是我們現在的散戶
是變成類法人
我們現在的融資
差不多4700多億吧
假如沒記錯的話
那目前看起來
假設是這樣的內容上來看
從過去的這個
散戶就變成類伐
類伐人他就變滾雪球效應
這個是我看到
我覺得這兩張
可以完全去解釋
這波行情的主要的一個有機資產
等於被動式的
可能大家之前已經算很風靡了
主動式更是有像
涌動機這樣的一個概念
沒錯 就是涌動機
就是一個circle
是
好 如果是這樣子的話
有沒有可能資金有
太過膨脹槓桿的問題
因為大家去買ETF
ETF買股票
而且現在還有大家都去借錢
對不對 不限用途的信貸
其實現在都壓到滿
你又講到重點
我說你們兩個主持人
真的是很專業貼近市場
怎麼辦 兩個飛起來
一個基本面
然後卻貼近市場
其實趙華觀察到重點
就是不限用途的部分
第二個就是融資維持率
你去看一下
集中市場融資維持率
現在是198
今天我們錄影的時間198
每個散戶都賺錢了
對
198代表你是
維持率是很高的
那你在OTC是200多
这是第一个
我们看融资维持率
第二个你去看
这个是过热的现象
融资维持率198是过热
我不是说这样很好
我说是过热
第二个就是违约交割
一月份违约交割
平均12.5亿
二月份我们放假
14亿
三月份挑到20亿
你知道四月份
目前看起来40亿以上
就是说它那违约交割的金额
是不断的派上来
代表是过热的这个讯号
第三個過熱訊號是什麼
BIOS
就是我們跟年限的關聯率
今天我們在錄影的時候
台股已經創下歷史新高
包括盤中跟收盤的位置
你就用盤中40,800點的位置來看
跟年限的BIOS的關聯率是
48,47%
歷史新高
是有過熱的情況
但是我覺得目前看起來
我們進入深水區之後
要觀察的是
資本支度計畫
我覺得這一波
為什麼走這麼急的原因
是因為四大CSP廠
它的CAPEX實在是太好了
其實我們看到
我們都覺得
這很感動
很感動都是錢對因為資本支付計畫是外銷出口的先行指標外銷出口是營收的先行指標營收是EPS的先行指標所以你看7700億
然後你再看Google
它的那個有效的Token數
1600億
然後最可怕的是
它的積壓訂單
4600億
那個是未來營收
所以我看到那個數字
真的是很感動
然後我們自己內部預測
是8000多億
所以假如這樣的話
其實我們之前
我們現在市場上所估的那個
我們的神山
其實它獲利數字應該是
應該是沒有太大的權利
應該往上走
但是就是說
我剛剛講的那幾個指標
是有些過漏
我用口頭這樣子來做說明
對
好 那當然的話
配置是無敵的啦
其實不管是1萬點
2萬點 3萬點 4萬點
有做好一個配置
以及享受所謂資本支出的紅利
不過這邊我還是想要再多問一個
就是我們現在靠的是
美股的湧動機
就資本支出一直給我們
他們會不會有一天發現
不能回收的問題呢
你這樣講就像
又問到重點
因為OpenAI它就開始有點
對啊
所以是這樣子
你講到踩剎車
其實就變成說
你在這個軍備競賽裡面
你會看到有人All in AI
All in AI就是用今天的獲利來投資
壓住明天的AI霸權
這個我覺得
會是
會是目前在
這個賽道上的膽小鬼遊戲
就是你再不投資下去的話
其實你就會被淘汰
其實我剛剛那張表
從2016年開始
進入2023年
那時候階段
其實你發現
那時候是Hopper
然後我們現在已經在
在第二階段是Black Whale
對不對
然後再來是Archart Rubin
然後再來Fearman
其實它那個四個階段
也剛好反映出那個獲利數字
所以假設剛剛趙華問的問題就是
假設我們看到CapEx有下來
其實那個股價就不會
像現在這麼juicy
就是一路往上衝
其實我覺得你
就是講到重點就是那個部分
那我們回到這張表的話就是說
我會建議投資人
因為我們的觀眾
百百種
有你的年紀
其實你所能承擔的那個β值
就是我們講的風險係數
其實比較不一樣
每個人都希望能夠找到那個
100檔裡面的千金股
現在千金股是將近50檔
500到1000塊的
也是差不多50檔
總共加起來也是90多檔
那目前他們這兩個類股的
平均本益比我算過
55到60倍
其實非常非常高
可是我們常常會用一個方式
去告訴我們投資人說
你不用擔心
是我把它的成長率
把它相除
除下來之後
其實是低於0.7以下
那其實上
其實還是可以買的
這是我們在看的時候
但是我就是用
比較保守穩健跟積極型
這三個類型
我覺得給我們的好朋友投資人
這邊做參考
那保守型當然就是
你的這個債券的比重
還是要有債券
對
我覺得債券這個位置
不是不能買
只是說你要拗
你要拗的話
因為你看大家賺錢
你在這邊收席
你會覺得
你肚子火
我懂
對 那個東西
對 那個東西我覺得
你可以以短債為主
因為假設說
現在短債從這兩年期
衝到3.9
那我覺得現在這個位置
相對是低的
所以你可以配置比較高的
這部分的債捲
然後在高股息的部分
然後定存跟貨機
這個是非常非常穩健
那應該是可以打敗
打敗定存
差不多十年公開值率
4%以上
不過這邊超級保守
還有貨幣型基金
對啊 定存
對 這個非常保守
我覺得現在台股投資人
很難選
這個我看應該
其實 對應該是
請給我積極的靠你那邊的
那就直接來看這個
積極的話就是高成長
那高成長我覺得ETF
應該是標配了
因為我剛剛提到那個
ETF 主動式ETF
現在14檔
其實他已經幫你做了選股了
因為現在的變化太快了
所以他的這種滾動式
這種滾雪球方式
其實應該是那後來
主動式的ETF
應該會馬上是挑戰
趙元以上
應該是在高成長的部分
我覺得可以配一些
主動式ETF
那主動是有三個層
有T1 YTD 6層
T2 YTD 4層
然後T3 YTD 2層
差不多你稍微少一下
就可以知道他的這個ETF
然後再搭配一些指數型的ETF
就被動式了
然後再搭配你自己選股
那當然要看我們富邦投顧的報告
我覺得比較順便廣告一下
然後高股息的部分的話
就是比較屬於Cash Stephen Year
我看一下台灣現在的股息
其實已經低於2%
並沒有這麼高的股息
但是你就是要去找一些
比較高的這個股息
然後再配一些債券
這個可能是在積極性的部分
我覺得可以拿來當作
是我們現在這個當下這個位置
做參考的一個配置
那以富邦投庫來說
以現在盤面上的熱門產業
有沒有一個所謂的排序呢
如果大家要選個股的話
以富邦投庫的報告
其實我
因為我們沒有把那個
那個所謂產業跟個股這樣來做
但是我習慣把它化繁為簡
我叫做駱駝投資法
駱駝了嗎
你看喔
CAMELS
其實CAMELS
這個東西是可以看的
因為
你不要以為原物料不會長
因為你去看這次的黃小玉
我今天為了上節目
我把刷一下黃小玉
其實黃豆玉米小麥
小麥長最多
YT長了26.8%
所以在CAMELS這塊
我覺得是可以看
哪怕軟的跟硬的
軟的包括塑化水泥
硬的鋼鐵
還有紡織近年有
所謂的試圖賽
其實這塊是可以看
CAMELS C的部分
A的部分就是AI
AI部分我覺得這個
叫做驗行理論上去
因為AI這個驗行理論就是說
它的領頭羊是台積電
然後左右兩邊有包括它的component
其實它飛累了回來休息
上面就頂上去
所以這個component我覺得是
是AI的部分是可以看A
然後M的部分就是記憶體
其實記憶體看起來應該
你們節目應該很多人在談
其實記憶體
它的這個cycle應該還沒有結束
所以這個memory的部分
應該是可以留意
然後E的部分就是energy
就是蛋糕的最下面那一層
能源
對 內存我覺得是可以
然後L就Lighting
就是我們講的CPU 矽光子這一塊
然後S就是Semiconductor
就是我們講的半導體
叫CAMOS投資法
我覺得可能在順序上
你就把這五個字母的類股把它放進去
然後稍微就放到你的這個
所謂的這個高成長裡面的一個配置裡面
自己裡面的一個配置
因為高成長裡面
你在分1 3分之1 3分之1
自己配置把它放進來
我覺得應該整個今年的
股市的操作上來看應該會不錯
好 其實以前光哥
還教過我們money投資數
還有party投資數
因為我想說你臨時Cue我這樣
我要趕快回答你一個比較
有整合性的這樣的一個產業跟個股
我覺得可能類似這樣的就可以
好 那今天很謝謝光哥
大來賓來參加我們趙華安倫說的
這個節目
我們第一集就請到光哥
真的是十分的榮幸
沒錯 學習很多
光哥還給我們很多信心
真的
就是我們問
然後傻的問
他還覺得我們兩個很厲害
應該是客套的吧
沒有沒有
真的很厲害
很貼近市場
對啊
謝謝